matthieu delormeau
si je peux me permettre voyez là
visiblement la production vous a pas mis
au courant mais désormais et à partir de
dorénavant je souhaiterais qu'on
m'appelle kader m'a tuer kader
complètement perdu parce que mes amis
m'ont fait remarquer tous même mes
parents et où il mendie voilà tu te
traînes tellement avec cyril tout temps
même le week-end et où tu as désormais
tout d'un tunisien sauf le prénom donc
nous avons réglé ce problème mais je les
choisis moi même ça serait mon deuxième
prénom - n'atteint plus que désormais
même pour tous alors voilà près de kader
keita kader si vous voulez mais nous
prenons bien d'accord mais regard de
l'ormeau kader delormeau oui kader de
l'ordre il va falloir changer le nom de
famille et c'est un truc kader de leurs
mots j'aime bien ça ne vient pas
retourné d'accord cyril ça fait très
tunis a aussi c'est pas faux
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
le racisme est patent du prénom moi pas
mais pas le passé j'ai besoin du prénom
vraiment m'identifier ça c'est le
hollandais ou au niveau de télé raciste